and to me is like rebellion the spirit
rebellion and they're gonna finish the
ceremony
the question is how they are going to
finish this ceremony well sacrifice is
illegal so we'll see what they come up
with
is being possessed always a bad thing
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hello everybody thanks so much for being
here in led live and let me tell you
we're going to be exposing darkness with
the light of christ and today this
episode uh please it's going to be so uh
intense it's gonna be a kind of hot
topic but let me tell you we're gonna be
talking about how we can be possessed by
the holy spirit and doing amazing things
or we can do
be possessed by the spirit of the devil
and we're going to do very damaged stuff
so let me tell you please do my favor
share this link with your friends and
family share with and social media
because let me tell you i know they're
going to be blessed and let me tell you
guys today i just want to share with you
guys
uh some
you know uh you see people you know
right i mean how they uh the holy spirit
changed their lives you know testimonies
and stuff like that but let me tell you
there are some people
that they don't want to deal with that
kind of stuff they want the different
spirit and we're gonna be i'm gonna be
sharing to you uh with you guys uh some
some different people's life and maybe
music and maybe something about
the modern satanism oh okay and so it's
gonna be a little different right so uh
just just
let's hang out
so
in the beginning i just want to tell you
that in matthew chapter 24 37
jesus he was saying that
uh like how was in noah's time
that's going to be
uh the sons
the son of man returns so it's kind of
like a prophecy tone like how it was
uh the time of noah that's gonna be the
time that when jesus is gonna be
returning and the question is how
it was a noise time right it's hard to
imagine because you think like you know
things have progressively gotten worse
and worse and worse it's hard to imagine
the world being at such a bad spot that
that god is like i i'm sorry i made man
you know like that's crazy to me it must
have been pretty bad though because we
look around right now we're like how is
it getting this bad well if it got bad
enough where god said literally only
eight people are worthy i'm gonna
destroy the whole world it must have
been really bad and sometimes there's a
misconception about what that time would
look like the antediluvian time like
solomon's saying there's nothing new
under the sun they were very much
technologically advanced like all the
the technologies that we have today sure
it might be a little bit different but
they were similar to what was happening
back then so
yeah that is interesting not only was
will it return uh in the same in a moral
way but i think also in a techno
technological way a scientific way all
these amalgamations and things i agree
the men had become one and there's beast
their minds gathered together
and this is what they've done built a
tower and all that you know that was
after the flood but still it's like
there was some kind of worldwide hive
mind thing going on which we can do that
today i can literally talk to people on
our comments that don't even speak
english and i don't speak anything but
english but i can just
paste it into google translator and send
something back to them and i'm
communicating you know
and i think gift of tongues given over
an amount of time too it's like you know
man
it's just like man can become evil but
can you imagine if you lived like 10
times longer than you right now like you
could
basically perfect your evil
you know and and i think like it could
go both ways you know like uh you know
if if if man was really truly bent on on
doing what god wanted him to do it's
like we would you know we would achieve
that but so yeah a friend of mine the
other day brought to my attention he
said you know
think about if if the times i know we're
like the times of today where
everything we do is like digital and
it's probably going to progressively get
to that way where like we don't print on
paper anymore because it's harming the
environment or something they don't even
print encyclopedia anymore everything's
digital imagine a world where everything
is digital
and then that world gets destroyed
how much evidence is really left of that
civilization
i mean that we find etchings and stuff
for like oh look they they wrote on this
clay thing we have evidence of it but if
it's digital in some digital clouds
you literally have nothing to go back
and look at what was the world like back
then
i was like whoa dude that's deep because
i'm thinking about like our time period
right now if we got destroyed and the
life went on for like a hundred years
and they're starting to dig up stuff
like
oh we found this plastic thing and
there's i don't know what it is but it's
really got like the world in it all
those
amazon servers that are in the base of
the earth you know i'm sure it'd be
preserving but they'd have no idea how
to
get that information off there it's like
what is this little sim card thing what
is that
yeah you'd have to rebuild something
like that yeah so he's saying that's
probably what the anti-diluvian life was
like it was all digital and then it just
got destroyed maybe maybe there's a time
period where there was a lot of stuff
that we just don't know exists because
it just got deleted and there's no
evidence
all the pictures and all the writings
just gone it's gone just in one second
so we were talking about the and the
time of noah i mean
i mean it was violence he was perverting
their minds and technology you know a
lot you know but let me tell you in
genesis 6 9 said noah a just man was
perfect in his generation
and
walk god walk with noah
so and that huge generation
it was a person
in god's eyes he was he was just
and he no
you know uh he was perfect in his
generation
and god say and and not work with god
i like that idea so that that god walks
with us it's not like god just talked to
noah you know what i mean it's like he's
walking with him you don't normally go
for a walk with anybody that you just
don't care to spend time with right i
mean when you walk with somebody you're
going somewhere and you're slowly having
conversation and stuff
um you know just i think it really kind
of adds this relational
aspect to to noah and what he had with
god it's it's more personal intimate i
mean i could be on the phone with you
and you're off somewhere else and maybe
you're in some situation but if god's
right there with you everything
is there danger i'm right here with you
man you're not like off far away
somewhere that's right that's so true
what you said because i remember you
know when i was a child my dad you know
we used to walk to get the the bus so
you need to wait like five blocks and he
always told me he said you need to look
where you step on
be careful what you stand on you know
and
you go camping or something like that
you need to be careful why you step on
it because it's a serpent or something
right so it's not just like hey talking
with everybody
to make you like hey alert be careful
give advice when you're walking you know
that's a good analogy too because if
your dad was just like i'll stay on the
phone with you while i walk to the bus
stop
i mean that's not very protective but
he's right there with you nobody's gonna
mess with you because your dad's right
there yeah yeah
yeah
so
also in genesis 6 22 they say noah did
everything just as god i commend him wow
he was obedient so and that crazy
generation
he was just
he was perfect
and he what we got oh god
and he did everything
whatever god commanded
so my question is
can we
be like noah
in this generation
we have to get to that point yeah
exactly
if the world was at a place where it was
so evil every thought was evil
continuously i don't know if we're at
that point yet because i think if i look
around there's still good people there's
still good
things that are happening in the world
that's kind of a crazy
idea to think about that every single
thought was evil continuously but we do
know that like you like you read before
that just as in the days of noah so will
the second coming of the son of man be
it's like we're gonna get to this place
where god's spirit withdraws from man
and it's going to be so that works for
the good and the bad as in the days of
noah a lot of people be wicked also as
in the days of noah there's going to be
some who follow his commandments and
walk with god and even says in
revelation that the dragon was wrath of
the woman that meant went to make war
with the remnant received who keep the
commandments of god and have the faith
and testimony of jesus christ
have you heard the thing that the bible
is like an arch that kind of parallel so
how it started is how it will end
so like just how you had the the garden
of eden and then there was sin and so it
started as perfection and then what
caused the sin and then you have noah's
um living in a time that it was full of
um you know men thinking evil thoughts
and was only the select group well at
the end of the bible there's a select
group
amongst all the evil in the world and
then a change happens to lead back to
perfection so it's like this whole arc
which is why the old testament is just
as important as the new testament and
you can see the language i mean that
makes a lot of sense based on what mikey
just said because in in in the very
beginning it's like you know we we
disregarded the words of god and in the
end it's like here's they that keep the
commandments of god and have the
testimony of jesus right here's a group
of people that are listening to the
words of god and are doing what what it
says like in the beginning we we didn't
do what he said said don't eat the fruit
we ate the fruit you know it's like
yeah we've come full circle around it's
an interesting point even in genesis
with the ten plagues that fell upon
egypt but the israelites were protected
we're gonna be in that same situation
exactly seven plagues are gonna come
down we're to be protected till christ
returns
so we i just want to you know encourage
you guys that
uh let's be like noah you know i mean
this crazy time that we're living let's
be just like noah and i can just imagine
just one one other point of like of hope
is that
the bible never mentions that god walked
with each family member
it was just noah and noah's faithfulness
saved his family that's right and it
just goes to our circle of influence how
our walk with god can save well yeah
salvation is individual of course but
i'm just saying um in this we can see
how big of an impact we could have on
those around us if we stay faithful to
that
god's protection imagine if god is
saying okay i'm going to protect that
home because that guy is in there that
husband is there well then your family's
in the home they're going to be
protected as well because god's
protecting your home so
in an earthly sense
yeah um but like i said salvation when
it comes to eternal life but
intercessory prayer man we were talking
about that a lot yesterday very powerful
and we cannot give up on anyone we need
to be praying for those we love when
they're lost i also think it's very
interesting how simple god was like just
get on the ark like like you don't have
to like you know understand and believe
all this stuff just just get on the ark
and people didn't get on the ark and i
think at the end like that's what god
says it's like you know come come be a
part of my people
and and join up with me you know
sometimes we over complicate it
that's our fault yeah and god it's god
is saying listen if you want and desire
you know i'll save you
and i can just imagine i'm i'm the kind
of person that i like to imagine a lot
of things i think and i you know i'm
sure everybody's like that but
i can just imagine noah preaching
his last sermon
i mean instead of like begging like okay
destruction is coming come inside to the
ark salvation is here i mean it's gonna
rain it's like what are you talking
about i mean water coming down from
heaven i mean we never see anything like
that but he's like please come but i can
just imagine
the enemy of the souls telling people
maybe there are people where they're
like you know what maybe this guy makes
sense maybe i gotta go in
but the enemy the souls always mess
around
like don't go with that he's crazy
you never see that anything
but let me tell you
like the story
sorry
but let me tell you just like jesus said
nos
time is kind of like prophetic time
right
so my question is who
obeyed to go inside the ark
his family his family who else his wife
the animals
so i mean can you imagine to see the
animals going to the ark i mean yeah i
mean
what a what i mean what a witness right
to be honest like why the enemy was
you know what that reminds me of again
not even signs and wonders
will entice people to follow christ and
that's what jesus was saying when he was
talking to the pharisees when they were
saying show me a sign which time can i
show you at this point you've seen me
heal people and just they they just saw
last week from raised to the dead
risen from the dead
you have you have all the prophets and
all this stuff
but that's a good point that they saw
these animals go in there and still
reject an organized fashion like that's
not normal
i mean were they used to i mean i
imagine okay if like we've got a lot of
occult stuff today i mean people are so
used to watching a cult junk in movies
and
seeing supernatural things
like if you actually saw somebody step
up and they were a real superhero and
doing these really like like miraculous
things
would you just be so kind of numb to it
that you wouldn't be like oh wow that's
interesting yeah he just blew fireballs
out of his eyeballs you know i feel like
even with satan's power and how what
he's able to do there's always a limit
so
something at this scale i don't know i
don't think that had ever been like
happened before or something that would
be considered normal well look at this
stuff we see like these magicians that
are on america's got talent or whatever
and they're doing things that nobody can
explain you know the whole crisis
yay let's see some more but they're not
thinking like this dude's demonic
possessed yeah that's true and they're
in
the bible like
god told moses to throw down his staff
and it turned to a serpent and then the
egyptian pagans did the same thing with
two snakes so satan has this type of
power we see these people on stage with
thousands of people watching even more
people watching on tv just
having a good old time just enjoying it
and not even once questioning
is this
power from satan right that's true so
the animals
these beasts they were
around the world well
they were insane in the ark right they
listen so it was a prophetic
right
so what is the animal represent
that wasn't the faithful
um
i don't know
i mean god's creatures yeah great
scripture but it's not supposed to be
people need to be inside right right but
let me tell you i'm going to show it to
you i'm sure you guys know who is brian
yeah right oh yes i mean the guy from
corn right yeah i mean that guy he was
so famous in that band right
i think he was playing the guitarist
right yeah yeah and let me tell you who
he
is going to the bank long ago
and i used to be in love with them back
so the these guys are going to tell
his story he's going to explain to you
what happened to him
so in my head i was like okay i'm going
to accept christ in front of everybody
right now then i'm going to go home and
snort drugs until i don't want to do
them anymore and that was my way of
thinking so i received christ
at the church i went home neglected my
daughter and put her in front of the tv
i remember i grabbed 100 bill i always
used a hundred dollar bill for some
reason pride or something
i chopped up my crystal meth
got it all smooth and powdery
and i snorted a big old line and i held
the bill and i looked up and i said
jesus
if you're real like that pastor said
then you got to take these drugs from me
come into my life come into my heart
and i just got quiet i said search me
right now search my heart
and i stayed silent and i said you know
i want to quit you know i want to be a
good dad for this kid
she lost her mother to drugs and she's
going to lose me if i don't quit
amen
[Music]
there's a high when you go on stage and
you see all these people like just
loving your music and loving you and
stuff and there's these girls and all
these people
worshipping me when you see all those
people just going nuts for you it's like
you know it puffs you up inside you're
like
you know
i'm important that's where drugs can
creep in and
you know cocaine or whatever
methamphetamines crept in
it all came from after drinking for me
and my friends and it seems like fun in
the beginning it's alive because it
it turns around on you it starts to wear
on your personality starts to wear on
your relationships
and everything is affected by it
negatively everything
there was a few times where
life seemed good my daughter janae she
came into the world and i was like it
was just
such a euphoric feeling
i thought my life could just feel like
that forever you know
it was like a
little spiritual just
i didn't know what was happening i just
felt so much love just fill my
emotions
and i thought i was gonna be happy but
uh
i just couldn't
i couldn't stay sober i didn't know how
i hit rock bottom
i'd swore
that i would never do methamphetamines
again
because i saw what it did to my child's
mother
it it just took her feelings away and
made her leave her kid
i just wanted her dead i wanted to kill
her i thought she was a scum of the
earth
and
you know how could she do drugs like
that and let it let the drugs win her
like that
so i never was going to do meth again
i ended up with a everyday crippling
addiction to methamphetamine and
everything that i said about my ex-wife
came true for me i sunk to the lowest
gutter i could ever think i would
spend time with my kid and i'd still be
on it because i needed to function i'd
get up in the morning having peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches snort meth
and then
take her to school or whatever it was
just i was a jungle i started losing my
mind this guy would show up in my house
with like a gun and stuff and then i ran
out in europe had my drug dealers crazy
send me drugs through
through the mail tweaked out my hotel
room watching this package come from the
u.s which is
nuts my life just was like spinning out
of control janae had come out on one of
the tours in the us i just remember her
skipping around the house singing one of
our corn songs called adidas
[Music]
about
sex
what am i doing i'm a junkie
my daughter's singing all day i dream
about sex
and uh
i'm gonna die
father
my uh real estate broker eric he uh he
said brian i don't mean to be weird with
you and i hope you don't take this the
wrong way but
i i felt the scripture like jump out at
me i've never done this before
you know so i don't
really know how to do this but i felt
like this would mean something to you
it's matthew 11 28 come to me
all who are weary and burdened and i
will give you rest
i remember all tweaked out i looked up
in the dictionary wary i looked up
burdened and
i just i pulled the scripture apart and
i was like
oh i'm weary and burdened and i need
rest
for my soul and
i didn't know if it was real but you
know they invited me to church a couple
a couple weeks later and i had received
christ
at the church i went home neglected my
daughter got it all smooth and powdery
jesus you got to take these drugs from
me search me right now search my heart
[Music]
fathers
i felt so much fatherly love from from
heaven
and it was like
i don't condemn you
i love you i love you it was just love
love and instantly
that love from god came into me
it was so powerful that the next day i
threw away all my drugs
and uh
i quit corn i was like i'm quitting corn
and i'm gonna raise my kid
because my kid like i got the love from
god coming to me and then it came out of
me to my kid it changed me my heart was
changed like that and i was like janae
daddy's going to be home with you all
the time i'm quitting my career
and her face lit up and she's like for
me you know she felt so special and
god used her to save me
to save her
life later on
my dream came true
way more than i dreamt about
i made more money i played bigger shows
i mean
houses cars
i tried drugs i tried sex i tried
everything to try to
get pleasure out of this life
and i thought that i could fulfill my
life with all this stuff
by by having my dream come true and it
came true
but it didn't fulfill it when christ
came in
that feeling he gives you
the gift of understanding life which is
everything was created for christ
and by him
and we're created to be with him
and it's the most incredible feeling
because
you're where you belong
and contentment
is given to you in life
because you don't have to look anywhere
else
and you're exactly
where you need to be
and the question about life is
answered i'm brian head welch
and i am second
so this guy
jumping in the in the ark
so we need to pray for this guy because
i mean he looks kind of like we talk
about the you know beast and all the
stuff you know all the stuff from the
from the world you know all the
scratches you know from from the world
but uh like you were saying i mean just
it's not too many stuff regulation you
just get in you know give your life to
christ and he's the one that he's gonna
be
watching us you know that's right he you
can't clean yourself up and then come to
god you're gonna be waiting forever
you're gonna make a few steps and then
fall back
he meets you where you're at i identify
with this guy's story so much i had his
book and i read it and everything and uh
you know he was doing meth and like
saying lord help me i need your help and
god didn't say no you're on drugs i'm
out of here yeah i know wait till i met
you where you're at in the mug
and uh that's the way it was with the
prodigal son too he's sitting there with
the pigs eating slop and he's like what
are you doing
i need to go to god it's crazy after you
listen to kind of a story of someone who
has achieved so much success in life and
you think like wow you know that would
just be amazing to have that person's
life and to have uh to be able to do
that play music for a living and that's
not but but you look at it and it's like
he's in bondage yeah peanut butter and
jelly and yeah
you know their existence i think if you
spent time with any celebrity i i think
you'd really see real quick
it's not what you think it is and and
really um we are like he said designed
to live a life that god intended for us
and our only true fulfillment is going
to be living the life that god fulfilled
for us we chase all these things under
the sun to try to make us happy and find
pleasure but at the end of the day it's
broken roads when you listen to
interviews of people who get to like the
height of their careers the one thing
that they always miss about when they
weren't famous was relationship how they
can trust their friends trust their
family now just a whole different world
throughout the interview i lost count in
this particular video how much he
um said the word feeling like i felt
this euphoria that and i thought this
would bring me happiness feeling feeling
so it's like you start with um being on
stage and getting all this praise that's
one kind of feeling but then it doesn't
feel the same so you maybe start with
drugs and you're trying to get up and up
and up and it's not until he
got the bible texts started picking it
apart and found a relationship with
christ that things changed it became
more um come let us reason together type
of thing instead of and put aside the
feeling i think that's what makes a
difference
the holy spirit working in his life and
he said here i am lord i need you right
but we're going to talk about this guy
i haven't heard about him in a while
but i know who that is okay you don't
know because this guy naturally you know
naturally everybody
so this guy right oh my goodness jack
black he made a movie a few years back
2003 right so it's called
school of rock and what we see there
it's a guy with a bunch of kids right
right
uh so i'm gonna show you guys the
thriller of this movie school of rock
everyone i'd like to introduce mr
schnapley all right look i've got a
hangover who knows what that means
doesn't that mean you're drunk no it
means i was drunk yesterday
i heard you in music class you guys can
really play why didn't anyone tell me i
think it's time we started our new class
project rock band can we tell our
parents no
lead guitar zack attack on bass posh
spice keyboards mr cool drum spazzy
mcgee so i don't know if you guys
remember this movie but let me tell you
this guy he's not a teacher
song his friend is a teacher
but he needs money or something like
that so he just went to cover for him so
he's in substitute teacher yeah okay
yeah substitute yeah or he's a tutor uh
well no yeah substitute teacher
substitute yeah
so he show up in the perfect
school and nice kids that they play you
know classical music stuff like that but
these guys love rock and roll right so
now he's going to turn them all
rebellious so yeah don't tell your
parents right yeah don't talk to your
parents about it don't tell your parents
and all the stuff so listen to you know
it goes on on the trailer they just pay
attention what this guy in the
background what he said once you've got
talent the story of a man who gave a
class the power to break the rules who
are they they're my bad i know they're
kids but they're awesome just listen and
the inspiration i pledge allegiance to
the ban
to rock okay so
i'm breaking the rules the regular part
of the contract when signing into
hollywood like you have to have this
message in your film
like i
i think it just boils down to it satan's
m.o and satan's ammo is breaking the
rules break through all this yeah it's
the lawless one and i think that that it
also is chipping away to this group of
people and if we really are going to get
to a group of people that that literally
follow the commandments of god and have
the testimony of jesus who was a law
keeper you have to fight against that
it's buying the devil time that's right
and if i was going to give you a grade i
would give you an a but that's the
problem rock ain't about doing things
perfect who can tell me what it's really
about
frankie
uh
scoring chicks no no
see no helene getting wasted
no come on no
leonard sticking it to the man yes but
you can't just say it man you got to
feel it in your blood and guts if you
want to rock you got to break the rules
you got to get mad at the man i mean
man's the one that made the rules right
you got to be mad at the one that makes
the rules and yeah it's all about
breaking the rules school of rock so
he's teaching
rock
to the kids
i know a generation but the thing is
that he's not teaching the rock of
uh uh
you know
but i'm not saying like the new rock you
know no the old rock you know all the
music you know ozzy osbourne and you
know all those guys right that's cool
yeah
i'm sure you guys watched this just
watch this clip in 2009
jack uh black he had this prayer
ceremony of the music mtv
awards
and he's praying
the question is who's who's praying too
[Music]
who wants to pray to the devil with me
who's in with me come on hey let me see
those horns let me see those horns
[Music]
we're supposed to like walk out at that
point that's right so i don't want to
play the whole thing because i believe
the the power of prayer right but let me
tell you he was dressing a little
different i mean this guy with the axe
and something
and he also says bro
legend
do you guys do you guys know who what
what is what does that mean no or what
it's about
so it's a name of
a video game
okay okay oh that's why he's dressed
like that's right that's why he dressed
like that and he has a one side you know
a guitar and the other one is an axe
so he's like i don't know if you guys
remember like playing the guitar and
yeah
yeah learning the music yeah all the
stuff
and
and i was like well what to check out
what he's about you know inside right so
he's just like a oh straight up saying
demons and killing and this is that from
the video game yeah from the video games
so okay this is not about music at all
well they're probably rock stars music
yeah yeah
see you there oh my and kiss slash and
all those guys
so they're you know these guys teaching
rock
or they playing the rock but they all
rock you know then like the classic rock
[Music]
this video he made this video
and
about when he was growing up
that he grew up in the christian home
and i didn't put the music because it's
a little loud and i'm saying about a lot
about stuff but it's a christian home
but he was
the the black sheep you know
and that's the family video that's right
from the movie uh
pick of destiny or
is that what it's called pick a destiny
is it the one where they battle satan
they're trying to get the pick of
destiny i can't remember the actual name
of the movie yes but so he loved rock
right and he's disobedient everything
and that is like you know that christian
family but to me it's like
he put this like
how he grew up and the call
how he went to hollywood
okay so and this video clip is gonna be
shown to you in this video clip
[Music]
this music
your heart will lose
[Music]
so the daddy goes over there and he's
like hey gonna tear down all the posters
and all stuff while you listen
and
if you live in my house you're gonna be
praising the lord here this is really
sad because i think sometimes when
people read the bible that's how they
picture god speaking to them
that's true honor your mother and your
father go to church you know like you
know love your neighbor and he's like no
because you love me you're not gonna lie
because
wow yeah
that's sad are you going to show more of
this because i can break down some of
your
yeah the clip yeah yeah he's coming okay
because i remember this
so the dad he forgot oh he left uh one
poster right as dio so this guy is very
known of the heavy metal like wow that
he's actually the one that is known to
to have made the horns hand sign famous
like if they say that originated with
him i mean dio did yeah it went back
further of course but he's the one
that's famous for it and that's just
continued to go on so listen to this so
the dad leave and he's there by himself
right like okay i'm gonna do anything
but
he's gonna do something
and he's gonna pray
to listen and look what who's gonna be
printed
theo can you hear me i am lost and so
alone
i'm asking for your guidance
won't you come down from your throne i
need the tight compadre who who'll teach
me how to rock
rock is not the devil's work it's
magical and rad
i'll never rock as long as i'm stuck
here with my dad
[Music]
you are hungry for the rock but to learn
the ancient methods sacred doors you
must unlock escape your father's
clutches in this oppressive neighborhood
on a journey you must go to find the
land
in the city of fallen angels where the
ocean meets the sand
you will form a strong alliance and the
world's most awesome bear
to find your fame and fortune through
the valley you must work
you will face your inner demons now go
my son
[Music]
so
what do you guys think about that i want
to point out something because for one
when you see the
the household we've seen this over and
over and over ugly dolls they made the
the place of the dysfunctional people
look all colorful but the perfect place
was all gray and drab this is the same
thing everything in the house was white
gray and drab
but he was saying he was trying to
justify rock it's not the devil's music
he's saying it's not from the devil and
then literally the poster says no we're
gonna go to hollywood where it's fallen
angels and you're gonna face your inner
demons and he's like yay let's go so
he's trying to justify by saying it's
not the devil's music and the viewer is
probably like yeah that's right it's
just rock and roll but then it's
literally telling him
it is yeah and come on and let's go and
he's like all right
let's double speak yeah exactly double
talk yeah
and this guy uh a few years back uh this
clip uh
uh jack black and the other gentleman i
don't know who's the guy yes kyle gas
yeah that's his like buddy that he's
always doing his music with that's right
so these guys they
they join together and they're doing a
like camping
tour
in california like in the weekend or
something like this rock thing and drugs
and you can do whatever you want in the
weekend
so they're going to be talking about
that and listening what they're going to
say what they did
everyone said just playing the devil's
music
uh and uh it was that great song that
never went down to jones
he had some devil in there and it goes
even back to before that who's robin
johnson
i was
so it's a joke they just did that he
said hey we sold our soul today i mean
it's a joke but they say it's a joke but
then they really
play it all out like that's just a joke
but let's pray to satan everybody oh
it's just a joke but let's call it what
it is
music right
yeah i think there's truth in in all the
jokes and he's he's probably um i'm
guessing
a real satanist and and probably really
subscribes to this ideology and how do
you get
something so obscure into the mainstream
let's make it funny and cool and fun you
know but that's fun you know just let's
pray to satan you know yeah look what he
says jack black says i don't have any
real spirituality in my life i am a bit
of an atheist but when music takes me to
the top it's like a spiritual feeling
and it fills that void in me so
even if these guys don't call it
satanism they're like open to the idea
and saying it like fulfills
a spiritual need well what's interesting
is
atheists who claim to not believe in
anything spiritual we'll still embrace
all these satanic things right let's
pray to say and let's make movies about
satan let's
i mean
and not outside of jack black you got
shows like lucifer and hellboy and let's
embrace this dark demonic
satanic figure but i'm an atheist which
is about breaking the rules hurting
people not loving people you know what i
mean it's like doing bad things it's an
atheist really in that context just
means i'm an antichrist because all my
posts on facebook are going to be
blaspheming your god why does why is uh
children can't sir bone cancer if god
exists when i look at an atheist page
and i'm not going to make a blanket
statement say every atheist but i'm
saying like
i see attacks on christianity over and
over and over like why are you spending
your time attacking something that you
don't believe exists i don't go on there
and say the easter bunny doesn't exist i
can prove it and you know why whatever
yeah they don't want creation taught in
school they don't want a nativity scene
in public they don't want the 10
commandments in public but let's make
movies that glorify satan
wait isn't that a biblical thing let's
get the bible out of public square right
right
deep breath mikey deep breath
so it's very interesting i mean we need
to be careful because in first timothy 4
1 said the spirit
clearly says that in the last days song
will deny the faith listening to
deceiving spirits and doctrines of
demons what i think is interesting about
that verse is that it says
some will depart from the faith
that's talking about people who are in
the faith you can't depart from a faith
unless you're in it yeah so this isn't
just like in the last days there's gonna
be a lot of wicked people it's saying in
the last days christians are gonna turn
from christianity
so that that goes against this whole
once saved always save thing as well
good point because you can't be well i'm
locked in no they're gonna
turn from christianity and give heed to
seducing spirits and doctrines of demons
i wonder if jack buck ever had
like christianity roots
for you to like dislike it so strongly
it seems like maybe he was raised in in
in that you know kind of a
maybe a super
you know conservative conservative home
or something that he rebelled against i
almost guarantee it with that i mean i
know it's just art it's a movie but i
guarantee there's
some kind of uh
inspiration behind that you know right
yeah
so
you know i just want to share that
example of how in the beginning you know
these guys you know just he asked god
for forgiveness and
come to me you know help me and stuff
like that so we see you know
the power the holy spirit right working
and in his heart and his life and
like we saw and i mean jack black i mean
all this stuff that he promotes you know
and all the stuff they
he acts or whatever i mean this is the
different spirit i mean you have to have
i mean it's only you know i mean good
and evil i mean it's not something in
between
so we need to be careful that so i just
want to share with you guys in 2015 this
is a video clip
uh on december 19 the satanic temple uh
in detroit held a ceremony on the steps
of the state capital
in michigan
and it's very deep it's a little
hard to listen because you know
sometimes we don't want to listen that
kind of stuff right but i just want to
share with you guys
uh
it's a ceremony just better than just a
ceremony and look at who's around
hail comrades
hail sisters and brothers and hail satan
we are gathered here to celebrate the
spirit of humanity in the dawn of a new
american era
in a season when many commemorate the
birth of christ
we commemorate our own genesis
the enlightenment of all humanity a
revelation of our nature as written in
the annuls of history
a gift from lucifer
the lightbringer the morning star
and the rebel
we are satanists
we engender moral spiritual and sexual
freedom
personal independence and insist upon
personal choice in all things
we care for the significance of the
individual spirits and personal moral
responsibility
if you stand here today and embrace your
nature
her free thinking self-governed and
godless
you too are satanists in the eyes of
many in your own community
including those who represent you and
your government what i think it's just
funny is it's like what is the main
problem with like
the concepts of the bible or
christianity it's like
to love somebody to not hurt them to not
lie to them to not steal from them or
take something that's not yours right to
not be sexually immoral outside of your
marriage like these concepts are things
that i think most people would probably
say yeah that's probably a good thing so
what is it that you're really asking
like that you want to do those things
because what are you fighting against
that's what i'm wondering i i've seen
some people in history
that
fight against the 10 commandments mainly
on the sex issue it's sex
honestly i mean she even brought it up
why bring that up in this thing you know
to have uh the sexual freedom or
whatever she said that's right i think
so because
when you think of of christianity just
being
for real it there is some sacrifice
involved you know when it says you need
to eat a certain kind of way oh but i
really love pork like it's a sacrifice
to give that up to follow christ and we
know that we gain more by making that
sacrifice but if someone wants to not do
that it's easy to kind of
like do away with all and join with a
group that allows let's using the
example of eating pork so you're still
going to
have your own moral code of yeah i'm not
going to lie i'm not going to do all
those things i really want to eat pork
so i'll just join this group and still
be
one thing exactly for that one thing so
in that sense i can understand you know
that they're not going around
doing like breaking all the other laws
so to speak but they just want to do
that one so they're going to join with
the group that allows it yeah because
they're going to tell you i don't need
your book to be moral i know not to kill
people and all this stuff and it's like
well where'd that come from yeah it's
written on your heart
so i mean she said i mean we're
satanists
and we got the moral sexual freedom
so it's not that we have some issues
that all this idea what this idea comes
from
that you can do whatever you can be
whatever whoever you want
and there's satanists
and uh
very interesting so this guy i'm sure
you guys know who's baphomet you know i
mean it has all beasts men woman parts i
mean all mixed right like a freedom sex
yeah
we are just as powerful as those who
work in this institution here
those who wish to uphold the traditions
of old feel us breathing
down their necks
and we will continue to be the voice of
reason to ensure that our america
remains free and equal
[Music]
all hail the eternal rebel within all of
us
to liberty
humanity and justice
to the satanic emancipator and end of
repressive traditions
hail satan
so it says the spirit of rebellion that
is inside of us
spirit
spirit you're gonna have the holy spirit
which makes you holy or the spirit of
rebellion which makes you more like the
lawless one so they're going to be
finished this ceremony
because remember that was the first
ceremony of the second
temple he was outside right
and to me it's like rebellion the spirit
of rebellion and they're gonna finish
the ceremony
the question is how they are going to
finish this ceremony a prayer to say i'm
sure
well sacrifice is illegal so why see
what they come up with so how why is
this how are they going to finish this
ceremony
[Music]
oh with a guy kissing
his face
so again it is about so i stopped it i
didn't want to keep going but thank you
so listen to that
that's the sexual freedom thing it
really comes to that
yeah that's interesting so this is a the
new modern satanism
that was 2015. and that's like seven
years ago oh and
i mean if we're gonna go down that i
mean you you go to a gay pride parade
and you'll see people dressed up like
they have devil horns and i've seen them
hold signs that say going to hell and
fabulous um
always jesus makes an appearance at
those parades
what why is jesus always at those
parades i've seen
naked women
nailed to the cross
i've seen jesus wearing a rainbow
outfits and stuff jesus always makes an
appearance at those parades
and they always glamorize being like
satan with horns and things like that
um talking about going to hell and
yeah it's just uh yeah there's a
they go hand in hand the sad reality is
i think a lot of these people you know
maybe they didn't get a true proper
picture of christianity i mean i'll i'll
play that that side too and and it's
like you know
i think it's really a calling as well
that that we need to be demonstrating a
a loving you know
a life that is enhanced because of our
belief in god you know
and and it's really sad to me that
they're rebelling against this but maybe
they're rebelling truly against a a
wrongful picture that they've been given
from their childhoods from the movies
from whatever
and when when when we get to the end of
this whole thing you know for a lot of
these people to realize that they live
so close to the end and
like there's a flood that's coming and
they could have just gotten on the ark
you know it's it's i think it's a sad
reality and it makes me it makes my
heart sad for for uh the way that a lot
of these people live because i i just
wonder is there really true joy in
living like that you know
is there true peace and and and that's
what the bible is promising us if we
adhere to the principles of the bible
god is saying listen
you will have a peace that passes all
understanding right it's it's a joy that
that um i think
living according to the principles of
god that you you live a more fulfilled
life
i just can't imagine being selfish and
doing whatever you want and even you
know having sexual promiscuity as your
heralding flag is not going to bring you
true joy and that's something i had to
understand
my my relationship with christ now my
understanding of christ now came because
or it started with the good influences i
had growing up i didn't grow up like
jack black i'm assuming the music video
matched his own experience with a bunch
of yelling in my household and you know
like that kind of um
confrontation you know it was more
explained and you know there was freedom
of speech and that we can converse like
all of that is important to getting
someone where they are today so we do
need to be sympathetic to people who are
in this lifestyle and
try to understand why or how they got
there right and i want to read a verse
in first corinthians 6 18 through 20 it
says
flee fornication every sin that a man
doeth is without the body but he that
committeth fornication sinneth against
his own body what know ye not that your
body is the temple of the holy ghost our
body is the temple
of the holy ghost which is in you which
ye have from god and ye are not your own
for
ye for ye are bought with a price that's
the precious blood of jesus christ
therefore glorify god in your body and
in your spirit which are god's glorify
god if our body is the temple and god
created sex within a man and a woman
marriage
there's something sacred
and holy about that act it says that the
bed is undefiled like god is in that
and so what is the one thing that satan
can do to attack the holy temple of god
pervert
that act right it says flee sexual
immorality because
our bodies are are the temple of the
holy ghost and yet it's like
with this act that we're talking about
is like going into the temple and
slaughtering a pig on the on the altar
it's literally like just
desecrating it yeah
yeah i mean i think that you know look
at what's happening here it's like the
devil realizes the best way to get to
you is to ruin the temple and
you know if if you destroy the temple
it's like
the god
leaves the temple and now your house is
left open and that's going to be able to
come in and that does go beyond
you know homosexuality that's what you
put in your body food wise you're
destroying your health what you
tattooing and all that stuff there's a
reason he says don't mark your bodies
like spray painting in the temple or
something yeah yeah
so nowadays we see
famous just
i mean one person's doing it i mean i'm
gonna do it too you know madonna senator
bullock you know all those famous i mean
let's do it they they see in the front
let's do it and when you
just saw that you know
as a wetness you see it i mean it's like
well might as well gonna do it you know
i'm gonna try or they weren't smitten
down from heaven when they did it so i
can right i mean
you know you see in the movies you know
and all the stuff i mean and remember
folks i mean the enemy is using
hollywood as the weapon to evangelize to
the whole world and what about music i
mean just to see i don't know i mean i
don't know what happened to music
nowadays it's so dark man i mean it's so
dark and what kind of spirit is that
jezebel
yeah i mean it's so uh interesting
that
i i just want to
tell you know everyone you know you know
choose life
you know choose good relationship you
know i mean
i mean just
i mean it's nice it's a lot of the whole
world up there right
uh
it's just we need to be careful what
kind of spirit we're gonna be
you know mess around when putting our
lives because let me tell you it's not
just like
uh this is my code or everything it's
gonna change your life for
for for destruction or for a blessing
and i just want to tell you guys
how the ceremony of satanists
it was ended and a kiss
right
with a ceremony and i think i asked you
guys one more time like what was the
last phrase of um
uh i
want to you know people are gonna get
married you may not kiss them right now
you kiss the bride right even the end of
revelation ends with a wedding ceremony
at the wedding center brad groom coming
to his bride us that's right
so it's so important how a ceremony of
somebody wants to be married isn't a
kiss right and i mean
i wish i i knew that before so i can you
know uh
you know i done it before but uh
it is so important to wait for the for
that moment so special so i just watched
this video and youtube this couple that
they wait they didn't have you know the
lady belief about purity and he said i'm
not gonna be kissing
uh my bride until i'm gonna get married
you know
and so i just wanna it's only like 40
seconds clip but i just wanted you guys
pay attention
how this this kind of type of ceremony
and that guy wait for like i don't know
a couple years a year and a half or
something not to kiss the bride
so just just just watch this guy how's
his reaction okay
[Music]
god brought us together today
the time is now begin to dream
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that you
so
it was so special right i mean every
time i saw i was like man i'm kind of
like i want to cry or something i mean
how special a simple thing like a kiss
is um we see it over and over and over
again you see the same actors in
different movies kissing different women
and you know what i find is very
interesting if you ever see like behind
the scenes of actual actors and like how
offended they are that their spouse
would be in a movie and
have a have a kissing scene with
somebody else you know what i mean and
it's like even in their profession
that's what they do for a living it's
still
a a thing that they feel is wrong that
should tell you how actually special it
really is and i wish that this right
here was more of the case of the way
that we treated that because i think
that um
yeah it would just be it was just it's a
beautiful thing when you see this played
out like the way god intended my kiss
and firmly like
yeah yeah that was more than just a
handshake you know right yeah right and
i wish you know growing up in mexico and
the
latino community i mean i remember i
mean growing up maybe five six years old
i mean some people like hey
your little girlfriend's here i was like
why do you need to put that thing in
your mind you have a
girlfriend or boyfriend you know things
like that and
the thing is that if we like you were
saying if we grew up thinking like you
know what save the kids for it's going
to be a special and you you got to get
married and i think it's going to be so
amazing i mean how we mess around uh how
is our sexuality
that's how it's going to be a
relationship with god you know i mean
because the enemy wants to mess up our
uh our
sexuality you know
how we think about about sex you know
and that's how is our relationship with
god sexuality is
uh illustration of our relationship with
god he talks about
how we should be like chasing virgins
and how we need to be that pure
the woman in pure white as and not the
harlot of babylon and in the old
testament it would describe him his
people as going a whoring after strange
gods
because they were cheating on god
yeah
so i'm going to finish with proverbs 3
verse 5 and 7 and says trust in the lord
with all your heart and not in your own
intelligence no acknowledge him and all
your ways and he will make your path
straight do not be wise in your own
opinion fear the lord and turn away from
evil amen so i hope you uh i just want
to share with you guys uh
that we need to be possessed by the holy
spirit because let me tell you we're not
possessed by the holy spirit i mean the
spirit of the the enemy is gonna be
coming and we're gonna be doing terrible
things you know in our own lives and
other people's life and
and we need to be careful you know like
the bible say you know
help us lord and help us to turn away
from from evil
don't forget to like this video if you
were blessed and also subscribe in this
channel and don't forget also to share
this episode with your friends and
family so thank you guys for being here
in led live and i hope uh this
this topic it was a blessing to you i
know it was a little a little heavy but
i just wanted to share with you guys the
with christ we can do anything so go up
there and share your light of christ
with other people because they need to
hear the gospel that's right
thank you we'll see you in another
episode
[Music]
you